nous allons commencer notre seconde
séquence
nous reprenons ce matin nos auditions
dans le cadre de la préparation du
rapport de la délégation sur la gestion
des déchets dans nos outre-mer nos deux
rapporteurs Gisèle Jordan et Viviane
Mallet qui effectue un travail
d'investigation considérable en souhaité
à juste titre un éclairage particulier
sur les aspects sanitaires de cette
problématique nous allons donc entendre
successivement au nom de la Direction
générale des outre-merdes jusqu'à
Stanislas foncy adjoint au
sous-directeur des politiques publiques
madame Delphine colle chef du bureau de
la préparation aux crises pour la
direction générale de la prévention des
risques Philippe Bodenez chef du service
des risques sanitaires liés à
l'environnement des déchets et des
pollutions diffusent Monsieur
Jean-François
Ossola adjoint de la chef de la
planification de la gestion des déchets
et pour la Direction générale de la
santé madame Caroline Paul chef du
bureau environnement extérieur et
produits chimiques et Monsieur François
clin chef de la mission outre-mer nous
rapporteur vous ont transmis leur
question sur ce grave sujet qui frappe
les populations souvent déjà en
situation de précarité outre les
pathologies ou contaminations directes
nous sommes aussi préoccupés par la
pollution de l'air des eaux du sol que
nous observons sur nos territoires
respectifs nous n'oublions pas également
qu'il y a des situations spécifiques
propres à chaque territoire comme la
gestion des déchets suite aux essais
nucléaires en Polynésie ou des déchets
issus de l'exploitation minière en
nouvelle-caédonie et en Guyane légal ou
pire illégales pour aborder ces
problèmes je vous cède la parole sans
plus tarder dans l'ordre que je viens
dénoncer ne rapporteur vous
interrogerons ensuite pour approfondir
certains points sur le foncis vous avez
la parole
bonjour à tous monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
merci de votre invitation c'est
on est là au coeur d'une série
d'auditions en fait sur la thématique
des déchets en outre-mer
puisque nous sommes déjà vus me
semble-t-il au mois de mai à la fin du
mois de mai c'était une édition qui
était plus générale on était accompagné
déjà à ce moment-là de la DGPR
c'est toujours pour nous évidemment un
plaisir de venir rendre compte et rendre
visite au Sénat et à la délégation
outre-mer du Sénat sur une série de
questions aujourd'hui qui qui porte
effectivement sur la thématique des
déchets et sur la dimension sanitaire de
cette de cette politique publique nous
sommes accompagnés de la DGPR et de la
Direction générale de la santé étant
donné la thématique étant donné la qu'on
dirige la technicité des questions qui
nous ont été transmises et puis leur
tonalité est très soit sanitaire soit
prévention de risques nous pensons que
va moins intervenir que les collègues
aujourd'hui probablement sur la sur la
série de questions qui nous a été posée
il y en a deux morts une petite dizaine
quelque chose de cet ordre il me semble
que sur la première question qui relève
des aspects généraux et des pathologies
contamination qui peuvent être associées
il me semble que c'est plutôt la DGS qui
va intervenir je peux très rapidement
balayer les questions en disant voilà ça
sera un tel et un tel qui interviendra
sur la deuxième question ce sera la DGS
également
sur les actions de sensibilisation la
deuxième question porte sur la
sensibilisation
sur la troisième question
prolifération des nuisibles ce sera la
DGS également qui apportera l'essentiel
des éclairages quatrième question à
devoir d'hégom et des GPR sur les
mesures de la qualité des eaux et des
sols
sur la Cinquième question les dateries
des JSD GPR et nous aurons peut-être une
assise côté déjà également sixième
question filaire REP DGS des GPR et des
géom là nous interviendrons chacun notre
tour 7e question sur les adaptations
réglementaires des GPR et DGS sur la
huitième question déchets radioactif
issus des essais nucléaires en Polynésie
ce sera la DGPR et je dis enfin mais je
ne suis pas sûr de moi non il y a une
dixième sur les 9e et dixième question
Nouvelle-Calédonie
Guyane on est sur la DGPR avec une
incise DGS et sur la dixième
incinération des déchets ça sera la DGPR
donc on le voit sous l'élection ils sont
très techniques c'est pour ça que les
directions métiers je dirais sont plus
sont plus sont davantage en première
ligne que là déjà pour cette audition si
vous le permettez donc on peut peut-être
passer la parole à aux collègues de la
DGS qui seront les premiers intervenir
sur la première question
une toute petite observation sur la
titulature de Delphine colle en fait ce
que vous avez cité tout à l'heure c'est
son ancien titre je dirais dans son
ancienne administration on se
rapprochera de l'administration du Sénat
pour pour préciser son titre actuel
du côté de la
monsieur le Président mais mesdames
laissées
la DGS vous remercie
vous remercie de que je représente que
nous représentons tous les deux je vous
remercie de voir s'exprimer sur le sujet
important des risques sanitaires liés
aux déchets dans les outre-mer donc pour
nous le premier constat c'est que les
impacts sanitaires liés aux déchets sont
analogues à ceux qui sont rencontrés sur
le tout le territoire français mais les
risques s'en trouvent augmenté
dans nos outre-mer en raison des
difficultés rencontrées dans la gestion
de ses essais tout type de déchets
ménagères industriels agricoles voir
sanitaire et de tout ordre de difficulté
en raison avec comme vous l'avez comme
vous l'avez ok l'isolement des
territoires leur taille climat leur
contexte environnemental et leur
contexte sanitaire et social
alors
quels sont quels sont ces risques quels
sont les pathologies ou contaminées ou
contamination
constatées le premier
volet concerne en fait la Bandon de
déchets sur les sur l'espace public qui
engendre des conséquences sanitaires
manifestent qui impactent qui impactent
les populations l'abandon de déchets non
collectés notamment les gros
électroménagers et les véhicules hors
d'usage les VHU qui favorisent la preuve
inflation des espèces nuisibles
potentiellement vectrices de maladies
transmissibles population
on pourra le détailler les déchets
favorisent ainsi la rétention d'eau
stagnante la constitution de visite
larvaire et entraîne
ils peuvent entraîner mais entraîne
aussi en la constaté développement de
moustiques vecteurs de différentes
maladies que vous connaissez chikungunya
paludisme etc
et puis c'est aussi ces situations qui
favorisent la prolifération la
prolifération de rongeurs de toute
tripes qui pouvait être porteur de
maladies telles que l'aleptospirose
donc bon plus généralement l'abandon de
déchets entraîne une dégradation de
l'environnement proche des populations
vous savez bien et notamment de la
qualité des eaux superficielles et
souterraines et destiné à la
consommation mais en fait la qualité de
l'air et aussi impactée soit en termes
de nuisances FACTIVE
ensuite au brûlage régulier en amont de
déchets à proximité des habitations
à titre de d'insistes vis-à-vis des
populations il y a eu une enquête qui a
été effectuée à la Réunion qui indique
que
86% des Réunionnais pensent que les
déchets dégracelets sols et 83% des
réunions aperçoivent les conséquences
pour leur santé soulignant également
leurs conséquences négatives visuelles
et aux actifs
c'est pas pour autant que 85% de la
population respectent les
alors sur
un petit focus par exemple sur un des
territoires que vous avez que vous avez
ciblé sur sur Mayotte les différentes
maladies vectorielles hydriques qui
peuvent être qui peuvent être favorisés
par par l'abandon de déchets j'ai cité
le paludisme tant qu'il est pas
complètement éradiqué il y a encore des
cas et on
[Musique]
à ne pas disparaître et à être et à
revenir dans tous nos de façon régulière
dans tous nos territoires que ce soit en
Martinique en Guyane à Mayotte voir un
Futuna ou elle est régulièrement on
constate régulièrement des cas et
dans nos outre-mer là on a vraiment un
cas de une très très grande différence
avec
avec la métropole concernant cette
concernant cette cette maladie qui a des
des effets sanitaires importants qui
peuvent avoir des conséquences très
graves et c'est une maladie qui qui
en particulier et qui entraîne beaucoup
d'hospitalisation
donc en Guyane à peu près une centaine
de cas par an en Martinique un peu moins
mais c'est un taux qui reste qui est de
l'ordre de 70 fois celui de la France
hexagonale donc c'est vraiment un sujet
qui est qui est qui est traité par nos
autorités alors au niveau des ARS mais
qui est très important
pour finir sur le
quelques maladies hydriques aussi
peuvent être donc suite à la
contamination des eaux on pense à la
typhoïde on pense à l'hépatite A donc
qui sont des pathologies qui
qui donc soit bactérienne soit virale
qui sont un qui peuvent donc être
contaminantes par
par le biais de l'eau
polluée par des déchets
produits par une personne infectée par
la bactérie pour la typhoïde ou par le
virus de l'hépatite
[Musique]
à Mayotte on a constaté en 2020
donc il y en a encore et
l'hépatite aussi entre 50 et 100 et 100
cas d'hépatite a constaté constaté à
Mayotte alors là un maillot puisqu'on y
est donc le RS s'engage beaucoup
d'actions
à la fois en termes de
d'action de veille de prévention de
traitement de prévention de traitement
des déchets pour limiter les impacts
sanitaires donc à différentes échelles
bien sûr dans le cadre de la lutte anti
vectorielle de la prévention donc des la
lutte contre le contre l'Égypte larvers
comme l'ensemble des comme l'ensemble
dans l'ensemble des territoires donc là
c'est la mobilisation sociale c'est
l'intervention directe c'est donc de
déploiement quotidien de moyens pour
identifier l'Egypte les gîtes à risque
dans les véhicules hors d'usage dans les
déchets sauvages dans les stocks de
pneus dans les appareils électroménagers
etc mais la RS en dehors de cette action
de base très importante aussi accompagne
financièrement les associations et les
collectivités pour leurs actions de
lutte contre les déchets donc la plupart
du temps dans le cadre de
chantiers d'insertion donc sur des
actions soit financées directement par
la RS soient cofinancé par différents
par différents acteurs donc dans le cas
de chantier d'insertion de avec en
collaboration avec les avec les villes
et les et les collectivités
il y a des en Martinique on peut citer
il y a des on peut citer des cas
particuliers aussi donc en Martinique on
a vécu à différents incendies
qui ont été plus ou moins bien maîtrisés
et donc qui sur des sites qui étaient
autorisés à recevoir des déchets et donc
là évidemment la RS est beaucoup
intervenu pour auprès du syndicat en
charge de traitement pour
pour limiter les risques sanitaires
induits et ça c'était en 2021 donc ça
c'est ça a été résolu puis quand on
parle de Martinique et de et de
Guadeloupe évidemment on a des
interrogations aussi sur l'avenir des
déchets issus des Sargasses qui peuvent
donc pour le moment qui
qui pose un certain nombre de problèmes
directs mais aussi dans le cadre du
quand on arrive à les ramasser après on
a encore un certain incertitude sur les
effets sanitaires que peuvent entraîner
les déchets en termes de
dégazage de d'émissions de d'ammoniac ou
de hydrogène sulfuré
c'est très désagréable et très
irrespirable effectivement tout à fait
on a une problématique aussi donc de
brûlage de déchets verts qui qui est
constaté dans un certain nombre de
territoires à la Réunion notamment
à
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon également
et puis on a des cas particuliers aussi
qui sont enfin des gars une autre source
de contamination et contamination
ménager enfin industriel industrielle
les deux ménagères on a constaté des
contaminations par le plomb
donc notamment à la Réunion mais pas
uniquement mais on a des cas qui ont
nous ont été transcrits par la S de la
Réunion
suite à l'abandon de batterie de voiture
ou de batterie de réutiliser de façon de
façon industrielle on a des on l'a
constaté des regroupements importants de
cas de plombées donc de saturnisme
infantile autour de
autour de zones de précarité avec mon on
a constaté c'est ses abandons de
ces abandons de de batterie ça c'était
en 2010 à La Réunion et ça a été résorbé
depuis mais il est quand même frappant
de constater que les dépôts sauvages de
batterie ont pris des proportions
importantes en milieu urbain que ça soit
en tout cas c'est à la Réunion j'ai
constaté aussi à Mayotte et en Guyane et
donc ça laisse malheureusement au des
pollutions diffusent
ultérieures
en complément des actions que j'ai déjà
évoquées
que qui sont effectués donc par les Arès
donc je passe un peu directement à la
deuxième question si vous voulez
les ARS effectuent bien sûr des actions
de sensibilisation du des populations
des populations et au sens là c'est à
dire à la fois le grand public les les
institutions les entreprises
au risque sanitaires donc aux déchets
alors on peut citer donc les différents
territoires en fait
des plans régionaux santé environnement
qui sont qui qui sont de
différentes qui ont
différents historiques certains récents
ou d'autres plus anciens mais tout sont
un volet de sensibilisation autour des
autour de la gestion des déchets on peut
en Martinique il y a un certain nombre
de de
d'actions qui sont portées donc soit par
les RS le rectorat la desals donc
instituts qui qui s'occupent de la
prévention et la promotion de la santé
pour la fraternité de communication de
formation des élèves
de
d'organisation de journée portes
ouvertes les restes Guadeloupe également
et
depuis ces dernières années beaucoup de
journées d'informations pour les sujets
de d'enlèvement des VHU les véhicules
hors d'usage et puis à Mayotte dans le
plan actuel 202 20 24 il y a aussi
beaucoup d'actions qui sont de
sensibilisation qui sont organisées
jamais suffisantes parce que quand on
constate sur le terrain on est toujours
de la difficulté
oui c'est ça
et donc des actions qui sont qui ont
comme objectif de réduire la production
des déchets à la source et de résorber
aussi surtout les dépôts sauvages sur le
territoire et ça c'est comme vous dites
on a
pas forcément les les résultats que
attendus en Guyane également beaucoup de
sensibilisation des différents acteurs
et en lien avec en lien avec des
associations notamment des grandes
associations telles que la Croix-Rouge
pour des projets d'assainissement
on a donc l'adresse à notamment
financier un projet dit wash qui
s'occupe à la fois de qui dans
l'objectif est de faire monter en
compétences les habitants des des zones
un peu reculées ou en précarité sur la
gestion de leur point d'eau
et promouvoir une bonne gestion des
déchets
associés donc ce sont ça fait partie des
projets qui sont vraiment très
très pragmatiques et très opérationnel
alors on a
je crois que j'ai déjà plus ou moins
répondu à la question 3 qui sont
concernant la prolifération des
nuisibles et effectivement on constate
on a constaté lors des enquêtes
environnementales autour des cas de
leptospirose ou de dingue des problèmes
sanitaires liés à la mauvaise gestion
des déchets pour autant c'est difficile
de
s'en en est une partie
et c'est difficile d'isoler là la cause
uniquement de la gestion des chaînes et
ça ça ajoute aux problèmes rencontrés
concernant les mesures donc comme vous
le souhaitez est-ce que je laisse la
parole peut-être à la DGPR sur le sur le
sujet
si beaucoup
donc je suis chef de service des
restanitaires liées à l'environnement au
déchets aux pollutions diffuses ce qui
fait que j'ai à la fois une
sous-direction qui s'occupe d'économie
circulaire et de déchets et j'ai aussi
une sous-direction qui s'occupe de santé
environnement
et
c'est un a signalé d'ailleurs que autant
notre nous a un conseil national de
l'économie circulaire pour la partie
déchets qui a une présidente qui est
Véronique Riotton qui permet de d'avoir
des discussions avec l'ensemble des
parties prenantes qu'elle soit technique
ou politique
autant nous sommes un peu orphelin dans
notre groupe santé environnement ou
notre présidente était
Elisabeth tutic Picard qui était député
qui n'a pas été réélu et donc nous nous
sommes en recherche d'un ou d'une
remplaçante
donc un service qui est censé assurer la
cohérence du coup entre la manière dont
on peut être amené à gérer les déchets
et puis la manière dont on prend en
compte les impacts environnementaux d'un
certain nombre de pratiques dont la
gestion des déchets donc si on prend le
cas de de l'impact peut avoir
une gestion des déchets déficientes sur
les épidémies de dingue transmises par
des moustiques ou autres insectes du
même type
on a différents types d'action pour
essayer de résoudre le problème un des
sujets c'est les véhicules hors d'usage
qui sont abandonnés au bord de la route
souvent et qui sont des lieux où peuvent
pululer les moustiques en question et
qu'ensuite ils sont porteurs de de des
maladies évoquées par mon collègue de la
DGS on a mis en place à la suite d'une
mission du député Serge de chimie on a
mis en place un plan de reprise des
véhicules hors d'usage par les
constructeurs automobiles donc c'est un
un plan qui permet de faire financer par
les constructeurs automobiles la reprise
d'un certain nombre de véhicules hors
d'usage qui sont des des repères
potentiels de développement de de
vecteurs de maladies rares enfin de
maladies
pour le coup pas nécessairement rare
d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui où est-ce qu'on en est du
plan constructeur on a
21437 VHU qui avait été repris en
janvier 2022
9000 en Martinique 4000 en Guadeloupe
6000 à la Réunion à peu près 400 à
Mayotte et à peu près 2000 véhicules en
Guyane
c'est un donc c'est quelque chose qui a
mis un peu de temps à se mettre en place
mais ça permet de débarrasser un centre
de véhicule d'abord dans le domaine
public mais lorsque on lorsque la loi
sur l'économie circulaire a été adoptée
en février 2020 ont été adoptés des
dispositions qui permettent de renforcer
la prise en charge de ces véhicules
notamment un article qui permet de
d'aller chez les personnes qui
détiennent de tel véhicule pour les
mettre en demeure d'évacuer le véhicule
hors d'usage en question on vient de
filière agréé
avec aussi un dispositif de police qui
figure à l'article l541-3 du code de
l'environnement qui permet si jamais le
détenteur du véhicule ne satisfait pas
cette obligation de rendre son véhicule
hors d'usage à une filière agréée de se
substituer chez la personne en question
de faire venir un camion pour mettre le
VHU sur le camion et ensuite direction
le centre de VHU derrière donc on a à la
fois ce plan des constructeurs
et à la fois aussi on a renforcé les
obligations
législatives réglementaires de manière à
faciliter la prise en charge de ces
véhicules
alors quand le rapport les chimie était
paru on estimait à l'époque le nombre de
véhicules concernés à peu près 60 000
donc aujourd'hui on en est au tiers de
l'inventaire qui est qui a été repris et
ce plan continu dans la loi Ajac a été
voté une autre disposition qui vise à
faire du sujet des véhicules hors
d'usage un objet
de des filières dites à responsabilité
élargie des producteurs c'est-à-dire que
partir du 1er janvier 2023 et bien est
censé se mettre en place une vraie
filière à responsabilité élargie des
producteurs ou les constructeurs
financent ou traite de façon
opérationnelle les véhicules hors
d'usage alors que jusqu'à présent
c'était un système qui était équilibré
économiquement en métropole qui
n'étaient pas équilibré dans les dans
les départements d'outre-mer donc notre
objectif bah c'est de d'harmoniser les
règles qui vont s'appliquer dans la
collecte et la gestion des véhicules
hors d'usage que c'est véhicule soit en
métropole dans notre même globalement
d'ailleurs lorsqu'on a fait adopter
cette loi en 2020
on avait des préoccupations spécifiques
au département d'outre-mer c'est à dire
que le développement des filières
responsabilités énergies de producteurs
s'est faite avec des règles qui
dépendaient un peu de chaque filière
donc 2020 on a harmonisé les règles pour
l'ensemble des filières puis on a aussi
mis un coup d'accélérateur sur
l'application des éco-organismes dans
les départements d'outre-mer avec des
règles spécifiques notamment où on
demande à ce que lorsque le taux de
collecte ou de tri de valorisation de
déchets dans une filière REP est
inférieure à la moyenne nationale et
bien à ce moment-là les éco-organismes
doivent compenser et financer plus pour
permettre un retour à une situation plus
normale de collecte et de gestion des
déchets donc ça c'est le cas pour les
VHU on parlait des batteries tout à
l'heure c'est un peu la même chose on a
aussi une filière responsabilité élargie
des producteurs dans le domaine des
piliers accumulateurs et donc des
batteries c'est une filière qui est
imposée par la Commission européenne
d'ailleurs
et là aussi et bien il y a un position
pour les deux écorganismes qui sont
chargés de ces collectes de mettre en
place des plans de prévention et de
gestion des déchets spécifiques aux
outre-mer de façon à rattraper le retard
qui a pu être pris dans les départements
d'outre-mer
et pour terminer sur ces questions de de
virus de la dengue on a également les
pneumatiques qui sont des réservoirs
potentiels puisque l'eau s'accumule dans
les pneumatiques et on a un
développement de de moustiques et
ensuite transmission de maladie
c'est la même chose en 2020 on a on a
fait voter un article qui prévoit que
les pneumatiques seront réintégrés dans
la législation sur les filières
responsabilités élargies des producteurs
donc aujourd'hui on était dans un
contexte où on était plutôt basé sur le
voltaria on va dire des producteurs de
pneumatiques pour gérer la collecte de
ces pneumatiques et on est en train de
travailler en ce moment sur les textes
d'application de la loi de façon à
pouvoir
disposer d'une filière responsabilité
élargile de pneumatique des producteurs
pardon pour la reprise des pneumatiques
ce qui fait que on devrait ça devrait
aussi permettre d'améliorer la situation
des déchets de pneumatiques en outre-mer
dernier point peut-être aussi là dessus
c'est que
dans cette loi de 2020 on a fait en
sorte que les écorganismes qui étaient
plutôt impliqués dans tout ce qui était
soutien
au financement ou bien gestion
opérationnelle dans la collecte et le
tri des déchets on les impliquait dans
la gestion des dépôts sauvages
et donc à partir de maintenant
s'applique une disposition où il est
quand on a un dépôt sauvage il est
possible de faire le tri en quelque
sorte entre est-ce que c'est des
pneumatiques est-ce que c'est des
déchets d'emballage est-ce que c'est des
déchets du bâtiment et il est possible
de demander aux effets organismes de
financer la reprise de ces déchets au
prorata de la composition des du tas de
déchets en question et donc ça c'est une
nouvelle obligation qui
qui est disponible dans l'arsenal
réglementaire et à disposition des
autorités de police voilà ce que je
pouvais dire sur ce qu'on fait pour
lutter contre les épidémies de dingue
on enchaîne dans l'enchaîne
ok très bien alors
ce qu'on peut dire aussi donc c'est que
globalement la gestion des déchets
d'outre-mer
à une difficulté intrinsèque c'est le
manque de disponibilité de filière de
traitement et de valorisation des
déchets en question puisque quand on a
des déchets d'acier ça se valorise dans
une assiie quand on a des déchets
pneumatiques ça se valorise dans des
installations pétrochimiques quand on a
d'autres types de déchets ça se valorise
dans des installations dédiées et donc
il y a un problème de filière
industrielle qui fait que
n'étant pas disponible dans la plupart
des territoires d'outre-mer il est
nécessaire de ramener les déchets vers
la métropole donc ça c'est c'est quelque
chose qui est une difficulté intrinsèque
à l'outre-mer
il est probablement possible dans un
certain nombre de cas de développer des
filières locales
alors le traitement ça peut être un peu
compliqué mais en tous les cas la
surveillance et le contrôle ça c'est ça
c'est possible donc là je citerai où je
reviendrai plutôt à l'exemple qui était
tout à l'heure des incendies dans la
décharge du Séron et de petits galions
en Martinique qui ont lieu entre octobre
2021 et janvier 2022 ce sont des
incendies qui sont liés à une difficulté
de gestion parce que l'incinérateur en
Martinique était à l'arrêt ce qui a
conduit un afflux de déchets assez
important dans les décharges en question
Une difficulté de gestion et les
incendies ont produit des fumées qui ont
pu exposer les les riverains à des
substances toxiques ce qu'on note c'est
que lorsque le service de la préfecture
ont voulu faire des analyses pour voir
qu'elle pouvait être à l'impact sur les
sur les sur les personnes
c'est difficile de mobiliser les
laboratoires qui interviennent dans ce
cas là donc il faut savoir que en
matière de gestion poste accidentelle on
a un réseau de laboratoires et d'experts
qui s'appelle le réseau Ripa qui a été
monté sous l'égide de l'INERIS qui est
notre appui technique en matière de
risque industriel et qui peut intervenir
notamment en cas de d'accidents
industriels ce réseau Ripa comporte une
soixantaine de laboratoires ce sont des
gens qui peuvent être mobilisés pour
intervenir justement dans ces situations
postes accidentelles pour savoir quelles
sont les effets en matière
d'environnement
après un accident bon ce qu'on a
constaté
fin 2021 à début 2022 c'est que ces
laboratoires là ont du mal à se
mobiliser dans un délai inférieur à 10
jours donc ça ça pose un souci donc ça
veut dire qu'il faut qu'on travaille à
la disponibilité de laboratoire
éventuellement sur place ou à la
capacité à faire venir plus rapidement
de laboratoires
pour faire des prélèvements et des
analyses en sachant que pour l'instant
si on a des analyses à faire il faut que
ça revienne en métropole alors il y a un
autre acteur qui pouvait être impliqué
dans ce type de d'événements c'est c'est
l'association de qualité de l'air locale
qui s'appelle madinaire qui ne disposait
pas à lui des moyens non plus pour aller
faire des prélèvements et des mesures à
côté de cette incendie parce que c'est
pas des moyens qu'ils utilisent en
routine donc c'est aussi un moyen
peut-être en tout cas impliquer
l'association locale de contrôle
agriculteur et peut-être un moyen pour
essayer de faciliter ce type ce type de
mesure
pardon
ah oui pardon made in hair
donc il faut qu'on il faut qu'on
travaille aussi du coup pas seulement
sur les filières de gestion mais aussi
sur qu'est-ce qui se passe si jamais il
y a il y a un souci
ensuite j'aborderai le cas de l'ensemble
de filière de gestion
et notamment parce que ça c'est souvent
un sujet à débat et en métropole et en
outre-mer mais particulièrement en
France d'ailleurs c'est l'incinération
donc
il faut savoir que le débat sur la
génération c'est un débat très
franco-français parce que dans la
plupart de nos pays enfin de chez nos
collègues européens quand on leur dit
chez nous c'est un gros sujet les gens
sont inquiets ils ont peur c'est
compliqué dans les autres pays nous
disons
pourtant c'est chez nous ça pose aucun
souci alors sa pose des soucis chez nous
parce que à une certaine époque des
incinérateurs de déchets n'étaient pas
conformes à leurs arrêtés d'exploitation
et ça a beaucoup généré de crainte dans
la population et depuis on traîne ce
passif
un peu comme un boulet alors il se
trouve que en matière d'incinération
c'est prenons un des domaines les plus
contrôlés les plus suivis les
incinérateurs doivent répondre à la
réglementation de la directive sur les
effluents industriels la directivité IED
l'ancienne directive qui règlemente la
plupart des secteurs industriels sera
réglemente les raffineries la
pétrochimie la chimie et bien d'autres
secteurs industriels et évidemment sa
règlement aussi l’élimination de déchets
et l'incinération c'est une
réglementation qui prévoit
périodiquement d'ailleurs une mise à
jour
déréglementation technique qui
s'appliquent sur tout le territoire
européen et évidemment c'est normal
s'applique également dans les
départements d'outre-mer
et nous avons mis à jour en tenant
compte justement de la dernière
évolution de ces règles techniques sur
l'incinération nous avons mis à jour
notre arrêté mystérielle sur le sujet le
12 janvier 2021 donc c'est des nouvelles
dispositions qui sont en train en
vigueur
ça ça conduit à fixer des nouvelles des
nouveaux paramètres en sortie d'un
générateur donc si je prends par exemple
le cas des notes dans les censé être
inférieur à 150 mg par la norme au mètre
cube aujourd'hui et éventuellement 80 si
on traite un quantité de déchets
supérieur sans mille tonnes par an c'est
pareil pour les dioxines c'est pareil
pour les poussières donc des nouvelles
normes de rejet et aussi on impose
régulièrement des nouvelles techniques
de dépollution à la sortie des cheminées
et donc dans ce contexte là
les règles s'appliquent la métropole et
les règles s'appliquent aussi dans les
départements d'outre-mer et ces règles
devront s'appliquer à l'incinérateur qui
s'applique en Martinique et ce que nous
ont fait remonter les services de la
préfecture c'était que l'exploitant
était en train de mettre son son
incinérateur en conformité avec ses
dispositions sachant en sachant qu'a
priori il est conforme au dispositions
qui s'applique à lui aujourd'hui donc ça
c'est pour l'incinération ensuite un
autre une autre filière
c'est les déchets d'activités à risque
infectieux
où là on a
[Musique]
on a deux types de traitement grosso
modo on a soit l'incinération et ça
c'est ça se fait dans l'incinérateur de
Martinique je comprends qu'il a des
déchets de Guadeloupe qui sont
incinéraires Martinique soit la
banalisation c'est un procédé qui permet
de
[Musique]
d'éliminer les bactéries qui sont
présentes dans les déchets
avant on voit vers les filières
d'enfouissement local
donc si je prends le
cas des Antilles on a eu 823 tonnes de
déchets d'activisation à risque
infectieux incinérer ainsi en 2021
les spécificités qui peut y avoir en
dans ces départements d'outre-mer c'est
aussi
l'implication de l'écorganisme qui
s'occupe de récupérer les déchets
d'activités de soins risques infectieux
chez les particuliers
puisque nous avons aussi un
éco-organisme sur le sujet que nous
contrôlons avec nos collègues de la
direction générale à la santé
ce qu'on constate dans ces oui
il s'agit de d'astries
c'est un organisme national c'est
l'organisme national qui qui assure la
oui oui oui ils sont
ils sont présents aussi oui absolument
ils sont présents et en fait ils servent
à financer la mise à disposition
au patient de boîte de collecte les
fameuses boîtes jaunes que vous voyez de
temps en temps chez votre dentiste ou
chez le médecin quand vous êtes quand
vous êtes patient et vous êtes en
auto-traitement vous avez ce type de
boîte et le et d'astrie finance la mise
aux disposition des boîtes finance la
collecte des boîtes et finance le
traitement des boîtes dans les dans les
filières dédiées donc comme on a
toujours un certain Delta entre les taux
de collecte en outre-mer par rapport à
ce qui se passe en métropole bon c'est
un peu le cas aussi pour ces déchets là
sauf que on est plutôt en train de
rattraper notre retard puisque l'année
dernière on était à 82 % de taux de
collecte de ces déchets d'activités de
soins à risque infectieux en
auto-traitement au niveau
national et on était à 75% en outre-mer
donc on est en train de faire des
rattrapages progressifs qui dépend un
petit peu quand même de chaque
département c'est à dire qu'on a des
taux assez importants à la Réunion ou ou
dans les Antilles on est qu'à 40% de
taux de collecte en Guyane par exemple
et ça aussi c'est peut-être une des
points marquants de cette gestion des
déchets c'est que on note des très
grandes différences de en termes de taux
de collègues de taux de tri de taux de
traitement entre les différents
départements d'outre-mer
et à la nécessité de d'améliorer les
campagnes de communication par exemple
sur ce sujet là donc en Martinique
d'astries finances des campagnes de
communication qui font qu'on a plutôt
des bons taux de collecte
la Réunion on collecte 20 tonnes par an
de déchets patients d'auto traitement
donc les taux sont assez bons aussi
et puis d'astrie sera réagré à la fin de
l'année puisque tous les cinq ou six ans
on réagré nos efforts organismes donc
ils doivent présenter un nouveau un
nouveau dossier et par rapport à un
cahier des charges qui est qui est
publié au Journal officiel et qui est
lui-même révisé donc d'Astrid a-t-elle
réviser d'ici la fin d'année les
procédures sont en cours et
mi-2023 il devra transmettre son plan de
gestion de prévention et de gestion des
déchets outre-mer
et là aussi on attend de lui des progrès
de manière à ce que dans les
départements où ça se passe pas très
bien aujourd'hui bah on fasse des
progrès et c'est le cas de la Guyane par
exemple
sur les Sargasses donc sur les Sargasses
les dgom également présentes
peut-être rappelé je ne sais plus mais
qu'elle est mis en place un plan
interministériel de lutte contre les
Sargasses en 2022
que du point de vue de la direction
générale prévention des risques c'est
très important de mettre l'accélérateur
sur la stratégie de broyage des
Sargasses collectées en mer
éventuellement reclaper derrière parce
que
le problème qu'on a c'est qu'une fois
qu'elles sont à terre c'est très très
difficile à gérer
c'est difficile à gérer parce qu'elles
sont chargées en métaux lourds elles
sont de temps en temps chargées encore
des cônes
elles sont très salées et donc
elle pose des problèmes si on veut les
réutiliser en fertilisation donc un
simple compostage et compliqué à mettre
en place
et donc on travaille aujourd'hui avec
l'ADEME mais aussi avec l'INERIS dont je
parlais tout à l'heure pour essayer de
sécuriser les stockages qui posent
problème aujourd'hui de façon à éviter
les émanations
d'hydrogène sulfuré qui évidemment peut
avoir des impacts des impacts sanitaires
je terminerai cette présentation par
deux sujets
particuliers je vais commencer par les
déchets miniers
puisque l'outre-mer et
un des territoires où il y a encore une
activité minière en France
donc les déchets miniers là aussi ça
fait l'objet d'une réglementation
européenne en 2006
qui a été transposé en France en 2010 à
la fois par un décret et puis un arrêté
mystérielle il y a plusieurs arrêtés
d'ailleurs mais
au moins un arrêté ministériel pour les
installations de stockage de déchets
miniers
qui correspondent à une rubrique dédiée
dans le dans le code de l'environnement
bon ce qui ce que vous savez déjà sans
doute c'est qu'il y a plusieurs types
d'activités minières ça va du de
l'exploitation à lui vionnaire ou on a
un procédé de traitement mécanique pour
récupérer l'or qui se trouve dans les
dans les rivières et qui lui va générer
des déchets plutôt inerte et qui
présente des vol assez faible et
toxicité assez faible le problème c'est
que pour les activités légales elles
sont contrôlées donc elles n'utilisent
pas de mercure par contre en Guyane vous
avez l'activité illégale qui se sert du
mercure pour faciliter l'extraction de
l'or
de ces déchets donc là il y a des plans
qui ont été mis en place avec l'armée
avec des gendarmes qui interviennent
pour démanteler les camps de mineurs
illégaux qui viennent du Suriname ou du
Brésil
et c'est
un travail de longue haleine parce que
régulièrement on envoie des militaires
pour démanteler les camps ils font ce
qu'ils peuvent pour essayer de d'éviter
de rendre le terrain inopérant pour la
prochaine fois mais on les voit revenir
et c'est toujours compliqué mais c'est
générateur de mercure qu'on retrouve
dans les
dans les eaux guyanaises
en Guyane par ailleurs il y a une unité
de traitement de minerais qui n'est pas
la lumière mais qui qui elle va générer
des risques du minier après traitement
chimique
et on distingue deux types de déchets
miniers dans ce cas là les stériles
miniers qui sont le gros des déchets
donc ça représente des volumes très
important mais en fait c'est de la roche
concassée qui ne contenait pas assez de
minerais pour ensuite faire l'objet d'un
traitement chimique et donc ça c'est
grosso modo ça correspond à la roche qui
à la géologie à la roche qui qu'on a
extraite alors c'est souvent
impressionnant c'est gros volumes mais
ça correspond à ce qu'on a à ce qu'on a
extrait et puis vous avez ce qu'on
appelle les résidus miniers et ça c'est
des résidus qui sont postes traitement
chimiques du minerai
et cela peuvent contenir des métaux
lourds ou bien des substances qui ont
été utilisées dans le cas du traitement
chimique de ces miner
donc on a un stockage en Guyane qui fait
l'objet d'un arrêté préfectoral et qui
doit répondre aux conditions définies
dans l'arrêté qui transpose la directive
européenne sur ces stockages
il y a à la fois des sujets de stabilité
de ces de ces de ces stockages parce que
c'est vous construisez des digues et
ensuite on met les déchets derrière pour
assurer la stabilité de la digue donc ça
c'est contre les c'est régulièrement
puis il y a aussi les substances
chimiques qui peuvent
qui peuvent émaner de ce type de
stockage et là aussi il y a des
prélèvements qui sont faits dans les
stockages et on s'assure que c'est pas
de nature à contaminé l'environnement
derrière parce que ça doit rester stocké
dans dans les stockages en question
ce qu'on peut ce qu'on peut signaler
aussi c'est que il y a un territoire en
outre-mer qui est
qui a une activité minière extrêmement
forte et c'est la Nouvelle-Calédonie
évidemment avec trois trois grandes
usines de traitement
de deux usines de traitement
pyrométallurgique et puis une usine de
traitement hydrométallurgie
où là les compétences en matière de
contrôle appartiennent soit aux
provinces soit à la Nouvelle-Calédonie
et là c'est un traitement très
industriel qui est fait de ces de ces
déchets donc avec à la fois des parcs
astériles miniers dont je parlais tout à
l'heure et puis à la fois des des
stockages de déchets de déchets miniers
de milliers
et il y a plusieurs initiatives pour
évaluer l'impact sanitaire de ces
déchets sur sur les populations locales
et je cite
une étude qui nous a été rapportée par
la dimension qui est la direction des
mines de Nouvelle-Calédonie
ça s'appelle projet metexpo et ça vise à
mesurer le niveau d'imprégnation des
populations locales un certain nombre de
polluants qui peuvent être émis par
l'activité minière comme le nickel
chrome le cobalt et le manganèse et puis
ça vise à évaluer si on trouve une
surexposition de ces populations
riveraines
autour de ces sites
les projets se poursuivent aujourd'hui
avec les recherches de facteurs
environnementaux en lien avec la
partition de certaines maladies comme
les cancers potentiellement liés à cette
exposition donc aujourd'hui il y a des
études qui sont menées pour voir si les
rejets de ces activités minières peuvent
être à l'origine de pathologies aux
alentours en sachant que ces activités
là font l'objet disposition de contrôle
un des sujets qu'on peut avoir dans ce
type d'exploitation minière du nickel en
Nouvelle-Calédonie c'est les émanations
de poussière parce que vous avez en tête
des images enfin sans doute mais c'est
ces images de de sites avec des terres
rouges parce que c'est aussi très chargé
en faire avec beaucoup de poussière et
donc il y a des travaux en cours pour
limiter les émanations de poussière lors
de ces exploitations minières notamment
sur les pistes pour pour éviter que ces
poussières se retrouvent embarquées dans
dans l'atmosphère
je terminerai avec une question très
précise sur les déchets nucléaires
en Polynésie française
donc on rappelant que entre 60 1966 et
1996 la France a procédé à des
expérimentations nucléaires dans le
centre d'expérimentation du Pacifique
qui est implanté sur les atols de Muru
roi et de fangatophore que ça a donné
lieu à des immersions de déchets dans
les années 60 entre 66 et
75 environ à la fois aux environs des
atolls murora et devant gâteau fan mais
également certains déchets ont été
immergés au large de l'atoll Dao
et
certains déchets ont été eux
stockés sur place dans des puits à Murua
et les quantités de déchets concernés
figurent à l'Inventaire national de
landra qui est l'agence nationale des
déchets radioactifs
donc c'est se passer les chiffres que je
suis allé rechercher sur le site de
landra on a
4192 m3 de volume déclaré de déchets dit
de haute activité qui sont les déchets
les plus dangereux qui ont été qui ont
été générés au moment de ces de ces
expérimentations et à peu près 10 fois
plus de déchets de quantités de déchets
de moyenne activité à Villelongue
qui ont été également
stockés dans ces dans ces puits
ce sont des déchets qui sont sous la
responsabilité du ministère de la
Défense
et en 1996
la France avait demandé une mission à
l'Agence internationale de l'énergie
atomique qui dépend de l'ONU la io a été
Vienne et avait demandé une mission
d'expertise sur
comment avait été quelle est la
soutenabilité de la manière dont les
déchets avaient été soit soit
immergé soit soit stockée dans les
atolls
et en 96 les experts à l'époque avaient
dit que
il n'y avait pas soulevé de
préoccupations majeure en disant bah non
il faut aller les retirer ou les déchets
immergés il faut aller les rechercher ou
autre
ils avaient dit d'ailleurs que contenu
la manière dont cela avait été fait la
poursuite de la surveillance n'était pas
nécessaire pour autant c'est pas
raisonnable de suspendre une
surveillance sur des objets pareils et
donc évidemment la surveillance de ces
de ces atolls et maintenu avec à la fois
des mesures de contamination dans l'air
et puis également des mesures de
communalisation dans dans la mer et donc
ça c'est des choses qui doivent
continuer à être faites maintenant bon
le ministère de la transition écologique
n'est pas le plus grand expert du sujet
puisque c'est le ministère de la Défense
qui qui est responsable du suivi de ces
de ces objets là et donc je pense que si
vous souhaitez des informations
complémentaires sur la manière dont la
surveillance est exercé aujourd'hui par
le ministère de défense je vous invite à
à l'interroger directement puisque il
doit il doit avoir des données
évidemment sur le sujet
voilà ce que je souhaitais dire
monsieur le Président
il me semble que les interventions de la
DGS et de la DGPR ont balayé très très
largement la dizaine de questions qu'on
avait évoqué au début il y a juste un
tout petit focus qui nous avait été
demandé sur Wallis-et-Futuna est-ce que
vous souhaitez qu'on en dise un mot
auquel cas je passe la parole à ma à ma
à ma collègue Delphine qui est donc ce
sera la première intervention devant
devant cette assemblée donc voilà et
donc elle va le faire très volontiers
monsieur le Président Mesdames les
sénatrices monsieur le sénateur merci de
m'avoir mis un petit peu de pression
du coup sur la question de Wallis et
Futuna pour revenir à la racine de la
question que vous nous aviez posée il
s'agit de la question relative aux
mesures régulières le cas échéant de la
qualité des eaux et des sols dans les
secteurs d'anciennes décharges non
contrôlés au sujet après caution donc
sur Wallis et Futuna nous nous sommes
rapprochés du territoire pour vous
apporter ces informations sur Wallis
dans un premier temps vous aviez une
interrogation sur la lentille d'eau
douce donc cette lentille fait l'objet
d'un suivi régulier par le territoire
avec différents piedsomètres sur
l'ensemble de l'île et puis ensuite sur
le centre d'enfouissement technique sur
Wallis ils ont également un piègeomètre
qui permet de suivre la qualité de l'eau
du site il y a des analyses qui sont
réalisées sur le territoire très
régulièrement par le laboratoire
d'analyses des eaux du territoire
pour les raisons évoquées précédemment
ces analyses elles sont limitées aux
paramètres bactériologiques et
physico-chimiques et néanmoins les
analyses conduites montrent qu'il n'y a
aucune pollution ni bactérienne ni de
dépassement de valeur des paramètres
physico-chimiques au niveau de ce
piézomètre situé sur le centre d'un
fouissement technique et puis plus
estompé dans le temps il y a des
campagnes plus globales qui sont
réalisées en termes d'analyse avec des
prélèvements qui sont envoyés en
Nouvelle-Calédonie et la dernière
campagne qui a été faite en 2018 montre
que tant d'un point de vue composition
chimique des eaux souterraines que
bactériologiques il n'y avait pas de
difficultés particulières le seul petit
élément notable concerne la qualité des
sols à proximité des dépôts et là ils
ont constaté en 2018 sur la surface
uniquement sur à peu près 50 cm de
profondeur une relative contamination
des sols par des hydrocarbures des
métaux et des composés industriels mais
que cette pollution superficielle au
niveau des sols elle semble bien
cantonnée au niveau superficiel des sols
et ne touche absolument pas les eaux
souterraines
donc ça c'était les résultats de la
campagne un peu plus élargi menée en
2018 sur Wallis et au niveau de Futuna
il n'y a pas de nappe phréatique ni de
ressources en eau superficielles à
proximité du centre d'enfouissement donc
on n'avait pas d'éléments particuliers à
pouvoir vous communiquer sur ce sujet
merci
voilà donc pour un coup d'essai
un coup de maître on peut le faire
la pression pour retomber je vais
maintenant laisser la parole merci pour
ces précisions à nous rapporteurs
tout d'abord vous remercier
que vos exposez exhaustifs qui ont
vraiment donc couvert les questions et
les que nous vous avions fait passer
donc de manière à rendre efficace cette
cette rencontre qui vient effectivement
vous avez entendu en amont de notre
mission avec Madame Mallet mais il était
important pour nous au pas à pas donc
lorsque nous avons fait des auditions
nous avons vu que cette dimension donc
sanitaire nous ne pouvions pas
l'occulter dans notre rapport parce que
elle fait partie vraiment intégrante du
sujet et on se retrouve comme vous
l'avez d'ailleurs exprimé les uns et les
autres sur des situations vraiment
différentes suivant les les
les situations des différents donc de
territoires donc ultramarins puisque là
où la collecte est faite de manière
rationnelle ainsi que le traitement et
ainsi que la mise en place des filières
Europe c'est pas les mêmes sujets que là
où c'est balbutia ou la collecte même
initiale ne peut pas être faite dans les
conditions les plus optimales mais en
revanche
les tas dans lequel se trouve donc les
les sites ont immédiatement cet impact
sanitaire donc vous avez donc balayé
donc beaucoup de champs je rebondirai
sur les
sur
l'exposé lié donc
aux déchets difficiles c'est-à-dire donc
à tout ce qui était lié donc notamment
en Polynésie donc à
les essais donc
nucléaires parce que effectivement
j'ai bien écouté attentivement la fin de
votre propos je crois qu'il fait que
pour que notre rapport soit complet nous
serons amenés à entendre justement donc
cette
le phasage avec le ministère de la
Défense pourquoi je dis ça parce que je
suis dans le département où on est
sensible à qui exploitation minière ou
en tout cas tout ce qui est déchet
difficile puisque nous avions en la
seule mine d'or donc qui restait
exploitée qui était celle de salsignent
c'est dans mon département et c'est
quasiment à côté de chez moi et les
risques climatiques que nous subissons
aujourd'hui ont réveillé des pollutions
historiques alors quand on parle de
déchets immergés quand on parle de
déchets enfouis et qu'on oublie le suivi
des sites parce que on part sur l'idée
que ça va être étanche on part sur
l'idée qu'il n'y aura pas donc de
difficultés particulières on n'est pas à
l'abri de voir se réveiller donc des
difficultés et notamment des difficultés
sanitaires puisque chez nous nous avons
eu des enfants touchés donc par
l'arsenic puisque donc il y a eu donc
des des
systèmes donc dit étanches n'ont pas
résisté et il n'y avait pas il y avait
des déchets salaire libre notamment
porteur d'arsenic qui ont qui ont fait
l'objet de pollution aériennes que nous
avons que nous ne mesurons que
maintenant donc tout ça pour dire que
c'est un aspect sensible de notre
dossier et que lorsque
la contamination est là qu'elle touche
des enfants ou qu'elle touche des
adultes on se rend compte que ce qui
fait quelquefois abandonner les suivis
sanitaires ou que ce qui fait abandonner
donc en fait l'oeil sécuritaire
puisqu'on se dit bon il y a pas danger
bon et c'est des questions de coûts tout
est une question on le sait bien tous
ici les parlementaires sont des
questions de coup mais je crois qu'il
faut pas donc baisser ce degré de
vigilance et les exposés que nous avons
donc entendu le prouve voilà moi ce que
je souhaitais dire sur cette première
phase mais ensuite j'avais un
questionnement parce que nous n'avons
pas évoqué les les
l'élimination des
des déchets d'origine humaine on a parlé
des daseries mais il se trouve que nous
avons été confrontés dans le cadre de
nos missions à avoir donc
des difficultés et surtout
la
les élus en proie assez problématiques
ne savent pas trop comment faire puisque
les classifications des déchets dit
médicaux qui sont qui font l'objet donc
d'une destruction dans les dateries que
ce soit au sein des des centres
hospitaliers ou que ce soit dans les
services connexes tout n'est pas ce qui
peut paraître pour le l'oeil du B au
ciel être un lit être lié à un déchet
médical n'est pas similaire en tant que
tel et on se retrouve avec des déchets
d'origine humaine qui pour certaines
sont éliminées par les services des
ordures ménagères qui se doivent de
brûler des des restes donc de
pas tellement envisageable parce que il
y a quand même la distanciation par
rapport à la personne qui procède ou
dans d'autres lieux c'est évacué je
pense chez à la Réunion donc certains
déchets de nature donc d'origine humaine
sont évacuées sur sur la Réunion depuis
Mayotte
les déchets c'est quand il y a une
opération lorsque tu as une ablation du
lieu de de d'une jambe ou une amputation
d'un bras ou du pardon
se fait pas à domicile donc ça rentre
dans les dateries il y a une instruire
pas du tout mais pas du tout dans les
hôpitaux il y a des filières également
oui mais nous ce qu'on a constaté on est
sur une partie du corps
moi je connais justement un principe en
principe il y a des réseaux
il y a des lieux où ça ne se pratique
pas voilà donc autant sur des lieux ça
se pratique et là c'est ce que je disais
les filières sont bien organisées et en
fait il n'y a pas on n'est pas confronté
à ce type de réalité mais il y a des
départements ultramarins où ils sont
confortés ils sont confrontés à ce type
de réalité et où il nous faut trouver un
procédé pour pouvoir éliminer ce type
donc de de
problématiques d'une certaine manière
donc comme on l'a pas ça n'a pas été
bordé dans les exposés j'aimerais qu'on
ait cet éclairage là si c'est possible
et moi j'adorais donc
quasimentchevé parce que je trouve que
tous les chats ont été balayés là-dessus
mais ce qui nous importe c'est pas ce
qui fonctionne bien c'est ce qui
fonctionne moins bien et surtout qu'on
puisse arriver à avoir tant soit peu une
harmonisation en tout cas qu'on puisse
préconiser dans nos rapports puisque le
plus le plus difficile ce sont les
harmonisations donc sur l'ensemble des
territoires puisque chaque donc
sénateur et élu un charge de son
territoire bon souhaite que les
problématiques soient abordées du mieux
possible voilà pour moi en tout cas
merci mesdames et messieurs pour vos
propos qui sont rentrés quand même bien
dans les détails et c'est vrai que en
tout temps le problème des déchets de la
collecte du traitement on ne peut pas
éviter d'envisager l'aspect sanitaire
c'est effectif mais alors moi la
question que je voulais vous poser c'est
une question qui a pas été traitée
par faut-il imaginer des adaptations
réglementaires ou législatives
le cas échéant dans le cadre
d'expérimentation dans cette et le et le
des cas échéant dans le cas
d'expérimentation excusez-moi dans
certains territoires et c'est vrai que
ma collègue vient de de vous citer des
problèmes des déchets médicaux dans les
placenta les trucs dans certains
territoires où il y a pas du Ve il y a
pas de
d'incinérateur il y a pas de crématorium
est-ce qu'il y a des solutions qui sont
envisagées est-ce que comment on peut
traiter ce problème
peut-être pour préciser certains points
sur la question des déchets d'origine
humaine donc ce qu'on appelle les Paoh
dans les pièces anatomiques d'origine
humaine donc elles sont
réglementairement elles doivent être
incinérées donc en fait c'est vrai que
là où il n'y a pas d'incinérateur
finalement il faut trouver un autre
système et donc par exemple en Guyane
c'est l'enfouissement enfin c'est
l'inhumation qui a été prévue pour ses
déchets et qui fait appel d'ailleurs à
des sociétés funéraires qui vont
s'occuper de cette inhumation donc là
dessus il y a un souci il faut trouver
une solution et ça là c'est le préfet en
Guyane qui a émis c'est par arrêter une
dérogation pour permettre cette
enfouissement
d'une façon générale où il est déchets
d'activité de soins ils ont plusieurs
ils sont de type très variés on va
retrouver des déchets chimiques des
déchets
radioactifs des déchets biologiques bien
entendu à risque infectieux des déchets
piquants coupants qui peuvent créer un
risque particulièrement
infectieux pour les personnels de
traitement de ces déchets et donc chacun
de ces de ces aspects doit être traité
et on est en train de justement de faire
un gros travail de révision d'un guide
qui était destiné à expliquer comment
gérer tous ces déchets qui de qui date
maintenant 2009 donc avec l'ensemble des
acteurs des filières et bien entendu
ministère de l'Environnement et
ministère de l'Outre-mer
pour donc mettre à jour et parler aussi
d'ailleurs prendre en compte aussi les
expérimentations parce que
il y a plusieurs il y a une
expérimentation notamment qui est en
cours qui qui vise à donc à permettre de
la valorisation matière aussi des
tasseries une fois qu'ils ont été
désinfectés donc il y a plusieurs
projets qui sont présentés en ce moment
et qui passent par France
expérimentation
qui propose donc des solutions pour
récupérer les déchets hospitaliers les
déchets de soins en général les
dispositifs médicaux tous ces matériaux
qui
représentent un grand volume finalement
qui que l'on pourrait quand même qu'il
faut que l'on traite de façon spécifique
et pour lesquelles on doit rechercher
des solutions
pour valoriser en tout cas c'est déchets
voilà c'est le point que je voulais vous
préciser donc et puis vous dire que ce
guide dont on espère au moins une
première partie début de l'année
prochaine
finaliser devrait aider justement et
prendre en compte ses évolutions aussi
du problème du secteur des déchets
hospitaliers ou de soins
oui en fait il y a aussi dans tout ce
qui concerne pour le milieu hospitalier
les effluents donc il y a tous les
effluents et qui a des réseaux bien
organisés également avec des marchés des
marchés publics un espace ça fonctionne
partout mais ce sont ainsi des déchets
liquide mais
issus de cet appareil quand on met du
sang par exemple pour analyser le sang
et d'autres types de produits ainsi que
toutes les vous avez pas évoqué les
pièces anatomiques mais il y a également
la conservation dans le formol et là il
y a aussi mais bon il y a des endroits
aussi un peu un peu je dirais un peu
mieux organisé que d'autres là où il y a
des incinérateurs il y a des filières
qui consistent aussi à
faire revenir aussi dans l'Hexagone par
exemple pour certaines déchets
nucléaires notamment et pour la
radiologie je sais qu'il y a quand même
des organisations qui sont en place donc
avec un nouveau ch pour l'hôpital bon
c'est une perspective il y a pas de P3
pour le moment il y en a pas
donc il y aura MP3 pour désactiver les
bactéries par exemple pour la
mycobiologie notamment et pour tout ce
qui est parce que mettons fait on
travaille beaucoup sur la biologie
moléculaire mais bon avec les sommes
froides mais il y a des choses qui se
mettent en place en perspective sur le
nouvel hôpital mais en fait la je ne
savais pas trop en fait pas un collègue
m'a expliqué pour donc demander pour les
déchets en question là mais c'est un
vrai sujet donc je pense peut-être je ne
sais pas s'il y a des simulations
d'incinérateur de ces endroits là mais
en fait j'avais j'étais un peu surprise
de certaines choses mais en fait elle
m'a expliqué d'accord donc il y a des
filières mais c'est encore
des choses à faire mais c'est
on peut pas tout avoir et tous les
dispositifs ne peuvent pas être mis de
façon contributante
la question du plan
excusez-moi oui vous avez évoqué ici la
question du plan du plan de l'usage du
plan qu'on trouvait dans le sol à
certains endroits il y avait aussi des
peintures sur les anciens bâtiments donc
quand il y a des peintures qui n'avaient
pas été refaites donc il y avait des cas
de saturnisme également récemment en
Guadeloupe après la tempête Fiona et
bien il y a eu une très bonne
communication de l'ARS pour la
leptospiose mais il y a eu quand même un
certain nombre de cas là qui sont
récents parce qu'il y a eu bon
évidemment tout ce qu'on connaît vous
avez parlé de la Guyane pour la
couverture Didas mais je crois que pour
la Guyane c'est particulièrement le
sujet mais je peux comprendre pour avoir
vu récemment les transporteurs il y a de
gros problèmes parce que les distances
entre les communes en Guyane sont
rentrés elles sont très éloignées
contrairement à sur le territoire
Martinique elles sont en train très
rapprochées et il y a évidemment le
soutien des services de
les amis à domicile qui aussi contribue
énormément au ramassage et la
distribution donc au plus proche des
gens et qui vont travailler avec les
pharmaciens qui sont dans le réseau donc
en fait en fonction de là on se trouve
peut-être que c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué par rapport à la Guyane ou
déjà entre les communes c'est très long
donc il y a pas les mêmes services les
mêmes rotations possibles et il y a des
endroits en Guyane où on doit se
déplacer empire par exemple donc là
c'est après ça complexe et fille tu peux
l'approche qu'on pourrait avoir par
rapport à des territoires où tout est
possible et tout est un peu plus proche
et bien coordonnées
je peux présenter une question oui
monsieur là vous avez parlé aussi de la
pollution des batteries qu'on retrouvait
régulièrement sur dans les ravines sur
le les bords de chemin tout ça moi je me
posais la question est-ce qu'il pourrait
on ne trouve jamais une bouteille de gaz
elle continue est-ce que quand est-ce
que il y aurait pas une solution je sais
pas de trouver une façon que quand on en
achète une véhicule vous allez pas sur
taxer le véhicule mais qui est peut-être
une un papier de consigne pour la
batterie et à ce moment-là
vous verrez que une fois que c'est
consigné que ça a une petite valeur
symbolique même à ce moment-là on en
retrouvera plus dans la nature peut-être
que voilà c'est c'est peut-être une
solution et qui serait je pense l'idéal
un ordre d'idée puisque je voulais poser
la question sur les batteries et tout ce
qui touche les VHU vous avez fait un
rappel assez exhaustif à des différents
règlements qui existent et textes et je
vous en remercie les uns et les autres
en évoquant le code de l'environnement
de 2020 me semble-t-il qui est élargie
la responsabilité des producteurs avec
des échos organismes qui sont censés
s'impliquer si j'ai bien compris dans
les dépôts sauvages et sur comment
récupérer les batteries mais mais aussi
les anciennes voitures
ma modès expérience réunionnaise m'amène
plutôt à penser que ce sont les
particuliers les communes et communautés
d'agglo parfois même les régions qui
aident à l'enlèvement des véhicules
usagés ou des carcasses de voitures
c'est souvent le cas à la Réunion
et et très peu les et très peu les les
vendeurs ou producteurs de voitures
alors comment comment vous évaluez
comment vous vous évaluez l'application
en fait de ce de cet article du code de
l'environnement c'est fait comment pour
la Réunion ça doit pas être trop
difficile puisque on a un seul on a un
une entreprise aujourd'hui qui qui a
beaucoup dans le domaine en tous les cas
de la vente des voitures qui qui a quasi
monopole de voilà de
vente de voitures donc ça c'était ma
première question et pareil sur les
batteries
madame ma collègue Viviane Mallet
entièrement raison il faut trouver quand
même une solution et il me semble que
pareil sur la Réunion la majorité des
batteries sont récupérées par des privés
et par ton container
en contenait à privé à Madagascar si
vous vous si vous connaissez bien
comment ça fonctionne
80% des batteries ne sont pas récupérées
par ni producteurs ni vendeur ni quoi
que ce soit mais par des citoyens
voilà et nous-mêmes on connaît des gens
qui à qui ont chez qui on dépose qui
mettent ça dans des conteneurs et ça
repart sur Madagascar et comme des pas
comme et pas comme déchets voilà enfin
ou alors circularité
et ça devient une ressource et ça vaut
pour pareil les pneus il n'y a pas il
n'y a plus de pneus à la réunion avec de
l'eau à l'attaque tout ça ça n'existe
plus tous les pneus sont récupérés par
des par des privés il y a même des
petites filiales citoyennes mais
vachement bien organisée et dans quasi
les 24 communes de Lille c'est voilà mon
expérience personnelle et celle de 90%
que
très bien alors merci beaucoup pour ces
questions sur sur l'efficacité des
dispositifs qu'on met en place
donc il y a une proposition sur comment
on peut améliorer la collecte des
batteries qui ont l'air de s'éliminer
toute seule
[Rires]
alors on a eu
au cours de l'été des discussions avec
les compagnies maritimes
parce que un des sujets qu'on a en ce
moment c'est la désorganisation du
trafic maritime après le covid et
certaines compagnies maritimes
[Musique]
ont vu un intérêt à ne plus vouloir
transporter dans leur bateau des déchets
dangereux
notamment ça a été assez problématique
cet été à la réunion et on avait des
conteneurs de déchets dangereux dont des
conteneurs de déchets de batterie quand
même qui
qui était qui était bloqué sur le sur le
port avec
des difficultés référentées donc on a eu
des réunions avec les armateurs et
notamment ses mains CGM de manière à
débloquer la situation on a encore la
nécessité de récupérer des batteries
dans les filières Haddock donc l'idée la
consigne l'idée de la consigne c'est
quelque chose d'intéressant que l'on
regardait il y a des il y a eu un grand
débat dans les voyageurs sur la consigne
sur les
emballages les bouteilles en plastique
ça ça a donné lieu à beaucoup débat
parce que ça
ça n'allait pas forcément dans le sens
d'un certain nombre d'acteurs
économiques et donc donc forcément dans
ce cas là il y a des débats je pense que
si on impose une consigne sur la
batterie on n'aura pas tous ces débats
là mais effectivement ça peut être un
moyen de récupérer d'ailleurs enfin moi
quand je rentre mes batteries chez
Norauto je récupère un bon avec un bon
de réduction sur sur la batterie que
j'ai acheté la prochaine fois par
exemple donc c'est aussi des choses que
les professionnels mettent en place
alors faudra-t-il imposer ou pas via
l'arrêté cahier des charges faudra qu'on
regarde cette chose là comment on fait
pour contrôler la bonne application du
plan VHU va effectivement d'abord on a
des gens sur place qui constatent un
centre de choses en général de toute
manière pour qu'un véhicule fasse
l'objet du plan en question il faut que
la police soit intervenue de manière à
constater la présence du véhicule de
manière illégale soit dans le domaine
public soit dans le domaine privé donc
on a aussi la possibilité de faire
un retour vers les autorités locales
pour voir quels sont les actes qui ont
été pris et qui permettaient ensuite de
venir prendre le véhicule et ensuite
l'amener vers les filières effectivement
dans ce cadre là je suis d'accord avec
vous il y a il y a une association de
constructeurs qui qui officie sur place
et c'est le cas dans tous les
départements d'outre-mer et d'ailleurs
là où on a les taux de collègues les
plus importants c'est là où les
associations étaient les plus fortes et
où elles se sont impliquées le plus vite
dans la récupération des véhicules là on
est très en retard c'est en Guyane parce
que l'association locale a mis beaucoup
de temps à se mobiliser pour pour
s'impliquer dans le dispositif donc je
prends note questionnement sur mes quand
il vous annonce 6000 véhicules là 4000
véhicules là est-ce que c'est bien le
cas je je
et parce que à la Réunion je pouvais le
vérifier quand vous avez une carcasse de
voiture dans une rue vous appelez la
police municipale puisque vous n'appelez
pas la police nationale fort
heureusement ils ont ils ont
suffisamment de boulot
et souvent la police municipale n'a pas
suffisamment éleve le temps et les
moyens parfois donc ça prend trois
quatre mois moi je peux vous donner
puisque les citoyens quand il y a devant
chez eux un dépôt ils vont voir les élus
c'est à dire que quand ils appellent ça
marche pas ils vous envoient à votre
permanence vous recevez des courriers
donc on peut très facilement nous
vérifier donc quand vous me dites 6000
voitures qui ont été récupérées sur la
Réunion j'ai beaucoup de mal à et je me
dis comment vous avez ces chiffres ou
qui vous les donnent est-ce que ce sont
les concessionnaires voilà concurrence
en l'occurrence c'est
pas la police qui qui récupère le
véhicule puisqu'il a pas la police n'a
pas les moyens techniques ni économique
pensez au micro
c'est juste enregistre derrière c'est
financé en l'occurrence et financé par
les constructeurs lorsqu'on doit
récupérer le véhicule pour l'amener dans
le centre VHU pour ensuite ramener la
carcasse vers la métropole ou ce sera où
elle sera recyclée
[Musique]
les constructeurs participent alors
ils mettent une participation la loi la
loi la loi a été modifiée il y avait
deux choses
[Musique]
aussi c'est quel ministère transition
écologique et collectivités
et Madame Paul et Monsieur Klein c'est
la santé bon parce que comme c'est
mission outre-mer en je me disais
j'aimerais que on se clarifie bien de
trop vous parler vous
dans ma question
c'est quoi une pollution diffuse moi je
suis un béotien pour ne pas dire
l'ignorons c'est quoi
deuxième précision un moustique c'est un
déchet
mais ça peut être le produit
au-delà de la politique comment on dit
ça en directorielle que devient-elle
dans les outre-mer comment c'est géré
maintenant lorsque il y a eu des
translations ensuite ça nous fit avait
mis au point un vaccin anti dingue
je sais pas si ça vous dit quelque chose
à sortir probablement vous pourrez
m'éclairer c'est une demande
d'information ils ont mis sur le vaccin
français un vaccin antidé on l'a essayé
aux Philippines
il y a eu des enfants qui sont morts des
enfants d'oiseaux que devient ce vaccin
quelle est l'actualité d'un vaccin
contre la dengue est-ce que vous
pourriez nous dire en termes de
recherche en termes pharmaceutique ou en
sommes-nous sur ça ouais
ça m'intéresse il y avait une usine en
Guadeloupe de DASRI et
Victor jasmin doit être bien informé il
y avait une usine qui
avait comme activité
l'élimination des Nasri cette émission
l'usine a fait faillite ou traitant
aujourd'hui les Dasies de Guadeloupe où
sont-ils envoyés on avait aussi un
traitement des pneus c'était Trinidad et
puis on a créé quelque chose à la barre
j'aimerais savoir qu'est-ce que ça
devient concrètement parce que je vous
laisse vous avez fait un explosé que
j'ai apprécié mais c'est vous m'avez
fait l'état de la législation quelle est
l'étape de l'action de l'État en matière
de gestion des déchets quel est le
financement parce que vous avez évoqué
le rapport les signes est venu chez nous
ça fait 30 ans Monsieur depuis 92 que
nous faisons les VHU en Guadeloupe et
c'est la Région Guadeloupe qui fait un
marché les constructeurs ne participent
pas du tout et quand vous conduit les
produits bruns ou les produits blancs
les remises de frigidaire le congélateur
ou que sais-je encore on ne les voit pas
on a créé toute une filière en
détroiteur avec économie circulaire et
je crois qu'on a bien inspiré ce rapport
là de Serge
ça l'État n'est pas là sauf pour les
normes sauf pour la police
administrative et j'ai 6 mois que l'État
est assez absent et je m'attends parlé
de nom et d'adaptation non vous venez
faire le contrôle mais il y a pas
vraiment de moyens vous pourrez être
raisonnable sur la responsabilité et
élargie moi ça a bien commencé et je
vois pas l'éco-participation du repas
des choses franchement et les
associations de recyclage de ressources
liées tout ça c'est nous-même qui
faisons fonctionner ça je les aides
d'État sauf si vous me faites mentir et
je serai très heureux d'être démenti
c'est Epsilon
franchement quand on parle de TGAP on
est même pas compris
tout ça c'est oui
c'est les déchets on est là uniquement
pour les sanctions
que personne ne pouvait gérer ben l'État
avait TGAP et tout ça sanction grève
délivrée
en économie insulaire c'est compliqué
et là il doit avoir une présence plus
active de de l'État alors écris-moi sur
les moustiques sur l'évolution diffuse
parce que j'ai été content d'entendre ce
que vous disiez sur l'incinération
aujourd'hui on a un problème aujourd'hui
mais un problème d'avenir on a refait
le on appelle ça le plan d'élimination
on devait avoir des quais de transfert
on devait avoir trois usines en
Guadeloupe
j'entends qu'il n'y aura apparemment que
qu'une seule et qui serait implantée à
l'extrémité est de l'île c'est-à-dire
moule
ce serait de l'incinération parce qu'il
y a plus de toutes mes canaux
biologiques apparemment c'est pas très
efficace je sais pas quelle est
l'alternative enfin quelle est la
solution de remplacement pour
l'incinération est-ce qu'il y a des
voies que qui autre que l'incinération
en tout cas je sais pas quelle est la
position de l'État sur le schéma adopté
par le Conseil régional en Guadeloupe
sur des offres qui ont été faites par le
syndicat mixte de
Munich
le civad la région notre projet et on
comprend pas très bien le rôle des
humains et des autres
et je dis ça c'est pas l'insoupçon c'est
une crainte pour que albio m'a fait ça
en fait ça on nous colle une usine
d'incinération à l'extérieur de libre
mondiaux de l'électricité je suis pas
contre le principe je suis pas contre le
principe de dire incinération au lieu
d'avoir trois usines ou de usines on a
une solution et qui va produire à côté
de
la compagnie thermique du moule de
l'électricité mais bon il faudrait un
peu le transparence au bon sache moi je
suis à 120 km si c'est pas plus du moule
on va prendre donc des camions ben pour
amener ça à traverser toute l'île pour
aller apporter ça ne se l'usine quels
sont les aides quelles sont les conseils
quel est l'encadrement moi je veux des
questions des réponses concrètes au-delà
de la législation quand il est appliquée
elle est simplement
administrative vu de haut surplombant
les collectivités et parfois la clé avec
des à la clé bon on va redonnez-moi de
dire ça mais moi j'aimerais connaître
l'effectivité de l'action de l'État
matière de gestion des déchets chez nous
voilà président une minute au fond et en
clair et c'est moi je vous remercie
d'être présent parce que vous êtes les
services de l'État et les différents
ministères vous vous coordonnez malgré
tout des politiques assez complexes de
de mise en place sur les territoires et
en lien avec les collectivités que nous
représentons en tant que sénateur nous
représentons ces collectivités nous
voulons trouver la cohérence et les
règlements qui qui sont aussi qui ne
datent pas de très longtemps donc cela
mis en application future en termes de
santé par exemple sur la dengue on ne
pourra jamais plus faire croire à un
Réunionnais que nous étions en phase
inter épidémique de la dengue il y a
encore un an ce que je reproche et je
franchement j'attends beaucoup des
ministères et du ministère de la santé
c'est que nous expliquions bien les
quatre phases progressives de la dengue
qui sont aujourd'hui bien identifiés
pourquoi parce que nous allons avoir
avec le vaccin qui a été donné parce
qu'il y a même des polémiques
aujourd'hui entre le vaccin covid la
prolifération de la dengue sur des
stades etc moi je l'ai attrapé
stade 4 c'était ma troisième dingue et
j'ai failli crever mais mais vraiment
mais j'ai failli crever à l'hôpital etc
il y a eu beaucoup de Réunionnais ça a
été un peu amalgamé avec la crise covid
mais beaucoup de gens sont morts de la
dengue à la Réunion pas du covid de la
dengue et et en fait on ne communique
pas suffisamment et je pense que nous
avons tous intérêt ensemble à vraiment
communiquer pour les populations plus
seulement à la Réunion à Mayotte mais
même dans le sud de la France bientôt
nous avons besoin de bien identifier les
phases commencent voilà donc c'est
franchement c'est je vais pas le relever
mais pas intérêt épidémique de la dinde
non nous ne sommes pas là nous étions
bien au-delà je vais je vais vous
proposer de ce qu'on va faire parce
qu'on a largement déplacé l'horaire de
la réunion et on a encore une phase
derrière c'est qu'on vous adresses si
vous voulez les remarques et les
questions qui ont été posées
voilà pour pouvoir y répondre pour
pouvoir passer oui
je voudrais quand même rassurer rassurer
notre collègue Victorin parce qu'il y a
eu une table ronde avec le civad avec
tout voilà sur l'ensemble des
territoires il y a une table ronde ils
étaient mix en visio et en présentiel
sur les problématiques qui ont été
posées qui sont juste mais il y a déjà
eu une table ronde avec le Sivan qui
était là avec tous les certains organisé
aussi présent en fait bon donc là les
questions qui sont effectivement de
vraies questions mais ça a été
traité dans une donc comme c'était le
côté sanitaire je ne sais pas mais je
crois qu'il faudrait y aller
il y a les questions diffus il y a les
questions diffuses mais et qui se
rapporte à des auditions il y a il y a
pas difficultés non non mais ça peut
renvoyer à des sujets qu'on a déjà
traité je vais conclure cette table
ronde en vous remerciant mesdames et
messieurs et sur l'aspect pièces
anatomique juste une remarque celle de
mon Saint-Pierre à Miquelon aujourd'hui
c'est illégal inacceptable il est bien
anatomiques ne sont pas détruites comme
elles devraient l'être j'en dis pas plus
le directeur de l'hôpital qu'on a reçu a
été très clair et mes collègues peuvent
en témoigner a été proposé un amendement
pour proposer l'acquamation
et il a été refusé je crois que le
gouvernement à mon avis a dû recevoir
des pressions de lobby de crématorium
dans la pâte crématorium chez nous on
n'a pas d'incinération chez nous et la
consommation sur un territoire comme
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon sur la
destruction des pièces anatomiques et y
compris sur l'incinération qui décore
qui n'est pas possible sur le territoire
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon et on doit se
faire incinérer pour ceux qui le
souhaitent au Canada avec tes problèmes
que ça pose notamment en période de
covid par exemple voilà je vais
interpeller officiellement le
gouvernement il y a une délégation de la
DGPR qui vient de rentrer ou qui encore
surmonteritoire ces jours-ci voilà qui
est rentré voilà et donc sans doute ce
sujet a peut-être été évoqué avec
l'équipe municipale puisque c'est eux
qui sont en charge de la destruction des
pièces anatomiques à la demande du
centre hospitalier mais c'est un sujet
vraiment important sur lequel le
gouvernement devra prendre une position
pour pouvoir trouver une issue
de Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon mais nous
nous le relèverons et on a proposé nous
proposerons certainement que ce soit
transgroupe parce que c'est vraiment un
sujet qui touche la dignité humaine et
on ne peut pas un certain moment donné
avoir des filières parfaitement abouties
lorsque tous les tous les étapes sont
remplis et puis donc avoir donc ce type
de problématique qui est vraiment enfin
moi j'en étais profondément choqué ému
parce que c'est pas possible au gré de
comme je l'ai dit d'un événement
climatique qui emporte malheureusement
des des paquets des sachets de de reste
anatomiques qui flottent dans la mer etc
et puis que ce soit à l'état de déchets
dans une des charges même pas
homologuées donc il y a quand même
quelque chose à voir à en ayant la tête
froide et en se disant que quand même on
touche là à notre propre intégrité
au-delà de la problématique
bien je vous remercie en tout cas de la
clarté des propos et on vous fera suivre
les questions restées en suspens pour
celles qui le sont merci mesdames et
messieurs et pour mes collègues oui
pardon
madame c'est ce que ce que l'on vient de
me dire alors c'était pas prévu mais si
ça ne vous dérange pas on peut assister
à votre exposé sur les risques
absolument sur des risques naturels
majeurs
oui absolument
c'est la troisième phase c'est la
troisième phase de la matinée c'est pour
ça que je me permettais d'insister sur
le timing dépassé de 45 minutes